I was anticipating this interview we've
never met until this moment I'm
wondering if the thought would come yeah
well the reason is that for quite a
while people have been telling me Conan
you look a lot or somewhat like this guy
joel edgerton and it's not just me I've
been hearing it from a lot of different
people I've been hearing it from a lot
of different people as well yeah I first
heard it obviously is this Conan the
character from the movie this may look
like what so Conan the Barbarian yeah
yeah no they think I look like you that
my characters in the movies look like
you that we look alike and right so I
thought well no one day I wonder if I'm
ever gonna sit in this chair and we get
to talk about it yeah well let's it's
it's not as I said it's not just us
these are real tweets that have popped
up like here's this first one right here
joel edgerton looks like the handsome
lovechild between Conan O'Brien and
Ricky Gervais
[Applause]
I'm not sure how I feel about this look
at this one is it just me or is joel
edgerton from warrior look like a really
tough Conan O'Brien what does that mean
I'm a tough Conan O'Brien I don't know
what these guys think okay look at this
one
joel edgerton from warrior could be
Conan O'Brien's brother you know the
cooler buffer it's just it's this is not
doing a lot for my self-esteem
there are I've actually seen in the
movies I sometimes I don't see it as
much right now but in the movies I've
seen we have this clip this still I
think which is from warrior where I can
sort of see that's definitely my body
it's definitely my body and I think it's
around the eyes I don't know Andy what
do you see yeah yeah you know I tried to
analyze it I don't think it is oh do we
do we yeah I think yeah put our heads
together turn that way well this way oh
that's too much imagine the baby we
could have this moonlit night yeah
you